no longer have eyes on the target
searching
visual
your support is on route
uh
um
let's get away
punches
where's mira we're ready to go needed
elsewhere she asked me to drive instead
which i'm assuming is her version of
running the parent trap a parent trap
yeah she's tricking us into working
together as a team
come on let's get this ion coil to
prospero ostiaro
you mind if i drive
i'd rather not end up wrapped around the
cap up tree you're not still sore about
that fruit stand in patagonia are you we
got there
eventually
hey move over
off we go
all systems go let's get this show on
the road amigo
so this mirror character how did you end
up in codes
came to find me in medici told me my
father built some sort of weapon
you know kid if you'd answered any one
of my 100 calls i could have told you
the same
all you do is manipulate the truth
sheldon it's only later that i find out
what you're really after
jesus kid is that really what it's come
to
shall we talk about what happened in
medici
fine if that's the way you want this
dance to go then that's the way it'll go
black hand units between mediolab and
prospero
they must have intercepted some army of
chaos chatter
be careful guys
that chopper's gunning for us rico
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
you and your army of chaos must have
these black hands pretty round up if
they're after you like this
seems like it
yes espinoza doesn't appreciate you
starting fires on this tidy little
island
yeah some fires need starting
taking a lot of damage here kid
is this the place
it's oh we're home
come on rico we'll take care of the
black hand on your tail
uh
[Music]
good
oh don't worry about that i have some
ideas for some modifications
nice shooting earlier
thanks
your people work fast
now you and mira got quite an operation
going here
they just want things here
to change
how's it feel
having an army
he's growing on me
seems like it
well i always thought leadership suited
you kid
we better make sure that boat has some
firepower
mirror and i got it all under control
we'll uh have her
ship shape for you in no time
oh hey rico
what do you want a neighbor
trick or something
how about
thunderborg
you